russian armored vehicles keep pouring
into ukraine
with one convoy stretching 60 kilometers
they are heading to ukraine's capital
kiev
these people look on in fear as russian
troops make their way through the
southern city of harrison also aiming
for the capital
people across the country are pleading
for the invasion to stop we want to
study we don't want to be afraid
stop the war
these students posted online
begging in several different languages
for an end to the conflict
millions of people have fled to the
western city of levive some to be
reunited with their families and loved
ones while others can only wait and hope
ukrainian forces are putting up a strong
resistance these russian tankers were
destroyed just northeast of the capital
and here a russian missile platform in
northern keeve is blown up by a drone
president velode mirzalenski is calling
for a no-fly zone over ukraine to stop
moscow's bombardment a request rejected
by the u.s
and as the missiles and bombs continue
to fall the front lines edge closer to
the heart of ukraine
leah harding al jazeera